Even though we can't split this into two separate inequalities and solve, this
inequality does tell us something. It tells us that the values of x 4 and
negative 4 are really important. If we did consider each of these factors by
itself an inequality these two points would be the end points of the solution
intervals. So let's say then that we're going to use these two points to break
the entire number lineup into three sections. One over here, one in the middle
and one over here. Now that we have these three different regions in our number
line, I'd like you to label each of those intervals with an inequality that
tells us what values of x lie in that interval. Make sure that you exclude
negative four and four.